Listen, so
Rabbinic Jews need the New Testament. Do
you agree with that?
Uh no, I do not agree with that.
Why not? Why not?
I I don't agree with that because I
don't think that anything ethical was
changed in the New Testament. You can
derive all of our ethics to hold to
uphold the
you know, a good life. You can be a good
man without needing any new
any new ethics or teachings um from the
New Testament.
Okay. Were the ethics changed when God
made a covenant with David?
Were the ethics changed The ethics were
So,
to my understanding, it it goes as
follows.
The ethics were revealed
essentially in the Torah, right? Uh-huh.
So, that was with Moses. Uh-huh.
And so, those are the ethics that we
Jews try to and Christians as well.
Yeah, so when God made a covenant with
when God made a covenant with Melech
David, David the Melech
David the King
was
was the morality changed? Were the
ethics changed from Har Sinai?
Uh not not necessarily. What do you mean
by that?
Well, what do you mean by the fact that
since the ethics weren't changed, we
don't need the New Testament?
Well, I I think that you guys, being
Christians, would still follow the same
ethics that is revealed in the Torah,
right? Yeah, but it doesn't mean that
God doesn't still make new covenant a
new covenant. Jeremiah 31 tells us that
God will make a new covenant with the
house of Israel and the house of Judah.
Unlike the covenant he made before,
therefore there's something faulty in
the old covenant and makes the necessity
of a new one.
So, what is what is faulty with it?
Well, that's what God said. God is the
one who said it's faulty.
God said that through who? Jeremiah? See
See See, that's I think the difference
here. Um we don't necessarily derive our
theology from the writings of the
prophets. We use the Torah, strictly the
Torah, right? And you can use others to
write commentary or derive other things,
but
Hold on, hold on, hold on. Is that what
Judaism teaches? Is that what Judaism
teaches?
It's it's not a
My view is not like the most Orthodox
view, I guess you could say.
So, I'm I'm looking So, my thing is Yes,
baby. Hi. Give me 2 seconds. So, you
don't you don't follow normative
Orthodox Judaism, right? You would agree
you follow a Rabbi Asher Meza type of
Judaism.
Basically, yeah. Basically, yeah.
Okay, you do. And so, the problem is is
that your
your position doesn't work, right?
Because you are odds with your own
sources within Judaism. What if I showed
you a source that said all of it was
given to Moses on Mount Sinai?
No, we we only believe that the law was
given
You You believe that or does Judaism
believe that?
There's no
uh how how should I say this? There's no
consensus.
Right?
Jews. You brought up Jews. Yes. Okay.
You You went to Yeshiva?
I did not, but I went to public school.
Are you with me Hebrew right?
With the Hebrew right? I do not I do not
speak Hebrew. I told you I did not go to
Yeshiva. No, it's okay. Avery, can you
put it on my screen real quick?
I'm going to show you how you're at odds
with your own Judaism, right? This is
Berakhot 5A written around the year 500,
okay? And this is very authoritative
source. This is the Gemara of Berakhot.
And basically, they're doing a
commentary on Exodus 24:12. It says, "I
will give you the stone tablets, the
Torah, the mitzvah that I've written
that you may teach them." Now, before I
say I don't say Asher Meza, I consider
him a friend. I like Asher Meza a lot.
Um but, this is a commentary on Exodus
24:12 where God where God gave Moses the
the tablets, okay?
And look, they're going to explain. It
means that God revealed to Moses not
only the written Torah, but all of the
Torah as it would be transmitted. And it
goes to say the tablets, when the Bible
says tablets, these are the 10
Commandments he got on Mount Sinai. The
Torah, these are the five books that
were given to Moses. When it says
mitzvah, this is the Mishnah, the core
of the oral law. That I've written, they
refer to the prophets and the writings.
That you may teach them, this is the
Talmud, which explains the Mishnah. This
explains that this that all of these
were given to Moses from Mount Sinai.
From Rabbinic Judaism's perspective, all
of these have the same level of
authority and they were all given to
Moses on Mount Sinai. I would say that's
where I would disagree, obviously. But
you don't disagree with me. You admit
that you disagree with the Talmud.
I'm not disagreeing You disagree with
the Talmud. Of course, there are
contradictions, there are
objectively wrong statements in the
Talmud, like
that's known, right? So
not every, you know,
uh writer of the Talmud is like an
authority,
right? So
like I don't hold them as an authority.
And I would say that many Jews don't
hold all, you know, teachings in the
Talmud as an authority, right? So
So, let's do this, okay? So, you
disagree with Judaism. This is a Jewish
source, this is a Rabbinic source,
right? And you agree that the most that
many religious Jews would disagree with
you, right? Saying that you can just
pick this up and put this down, right?
You agree this is not normative Judaism,
right?
I I do agree that this is not what they
teach you at Habod, yes. Okay. You would
agree that the Mishnah is authoritative.
Yes. I would say I would say so. I mean,
I would say so, sure. The Mishnah is
authoritative, right? If you follow
Asher Meza Judaism, then that's the
Torah and the Mishnah.
Okay.
Or are you deviating from Asher Meza
Judaism as well?
I I I I've only been on like one of his
lives, so
Okay. I I can't confirm. All right. All
right. All right, let me show you let me
show you a passage. I want you to think
about this. And I love to talk to you
some more, right? But let's go to Exodus
25 uh
25:40, I think it is. And we've talked
about this before in the stream. Let me
Let me actually find the exact one for
you.
Um
Exodus 25:40, yes. Let's do this, all
right? Exodus 25:40. Let me show you
something. When he's showing him
all of the implementations that are
going to be used in the in the
tabernacle in the Mishkan, okay?
He tells Moses to make them after the
pattern that was shown you on the
mountain.
What was Moses shown on the mountain?
Moses was shown the Ten Commandments,
the Torah.
No, this is the tabernacle. He was shown
the implementations and the dishes from
a tabernacle in heaven.
Okay, I I follow your point. Right?
Is Exodus in the Torah?
The first five books?
Yes.
Is this authoritative for you? 100% it
is.
So, what this is telling us, and look at
what the rabbis tell us. The rabbis go
on to say that Moses literally saw the
Mishkan, the tabernacle, and the vessels
from the tabernacle that exist in
heaven.
Okay, I follow.
Okay.
So, this Is there ever a tabernacle
without a Kohuna, without a priesthood?
No.
So, that means there's a priesthood from
heaven
that we have from the authoritative
source of the Book of Exodus.
Okay, I follow.
So, this is the This priesthood is the
priesthood that the Messiah serves at,
which is outside of Levi.
Levite.
Mhm.
So, what I'm saying is even in your own
authority, what you consider the most
authoritative, Exodus 25
it's proving to us that there is a
tabernacle in heaven.
There's a priesthood in there. And
therefore, shows us that there's a
priesthood in the Book of Exodus that's
greater than the priesthood of
Leviticus.
Yep, I follow.
And so, without the other five books
without any other books after Exodus and
without the New Testament you don't know
that priesthood that's from heaven.
This is why you need the New Testament.
And so your your position is
this priesthood that Moses saw is the
priest of what the Messiah of Jesus?
This is the Melchizedekian priesthood
that Melchizedek served that. And this
is one the Messiah served that that goes
back to heaven and predates Melchizedek.
Okay.
So this is why you need a New Testament.
So
in your in your opinion
how should I word this? In your opinion
you think that the
the covenant
that
God gave
the old what you would call the old
is no longer valid because of
of what?
I never said it wasn't valid. He used
the Jesus.
So then why do we need a new one? So let
me ask you a question. Let me ask you a
question. Yeah.
When
God told Noah
to build the ark
could God tell Noah I'm good man. I'm
just not going to go inside the Garden
of Eden. I'll stay out of it.
Was that okay?
So when
God told Noah to build the ark
and you
Could he just say I'm good. I'm going to
do like Adam and Eve and just not go
into the garden.
Could he opt out to not build the ark?
Could Noah have opted out? Yeah.
I mean he had free will. He could have.
Would that have been would that have
been an appropriate response to God that
would have been honoring to him? Okay.
not.
So when God told Abraham
leave your land leave your place go to
the place I'm going to show you. He goes
no. I'm good. Instead I'll build an ark.
Could Abraham do that?
No.
Right? Okay. Now, let's go forward,
okay? Abraham, Isaac, Jacob, you go to
Joseph, he frees the people up. God
appears to Moses in a burning bush, the
Malakh Adonai, the angel of the Lord
appears to him. He says, "Moses, Moses,
go deliver my people." Would it be uh
appropriate before a holy God for Moses
to say,
"You know what? I'd much rather just
leave where I'm at and go to a different
place like Abraham."
Mhm.
I'm sorry, I didn't catch the first half
of that.
be appropriate for
[clears throat]
Moses to say, "I don't want to deliver
the people. I'd much rather just do what
the other Right?" So, then we go forward
to King David. King David's called to be
the king. God makes a covenant with him.
Is it appropriate for David to say, "You
know what? I don't want to really be
king. I don't want to rule the king."
Would that be pleasing to God? He just
says, "Look, I'm just good to go up to
Mount Sinai and receive the Ten
Commandments."
No.
Why is that not appropriate for him to
operate in covenants that existed
before, only?
Because
Well,
if if David was given instruction from
God,
Mhm. right?
Then, that is
by honoring God, he he should follow the
these instructions.
He should operate in the covenant that's
in existence at his time, right?
Okay, I follow.
No, I actually asked you a question,
young man.
He should operate in the covenant. He
should operate in the covenant of his
time, right? Okay, yes.
Right? So, when the new covenant's made,
as it states in Jeremiah 31,
you and I should operate in the covenant
that's in existence at that time. We
can't go back to Mount Sinai, correct?
Here's where Here's where things are
different between you and I's
perspective, so is it How is it
different if it's a covenant that God
made with the seed when he calls his
people to?
Because
in Jeremiah
Right.
You have a decision right now. You have
a decision right now. I'm going to just
help you out. Okay.
a decision right now to be honest and
say, "You know what? That's a good
point. Let me go think about it." Or you
could try to dance through this and it's
just going to make you look silly. I'm
not dancing. Do what you got to do. Do
what you got to do, but I'm just letting
you know.
I'm explaining my position. All right.
So, Go ahead. Go ahead. I'm just like
I'm just trying to help you out. You
know, but go ahead.
Okay. Like Like I said previously,
the point of
the prophets
The point of the prophets is not to
add a new covenant. Right? So, that's
where you're getting this idea of the
new covenant from Jeremiah. Right?
[clears throat]
Did God make a covenant with Noah?
Uh I don't believe so. No.
Well, bro. Yeah, he made a covenant with
Noah to never flood the earth. And the
covenant was with the whole earth, but
Noah was the Okay. Sure. Sure. I see
what you're saying.
Yes.
Okay.
But then he makes another covenant with
Moses. Then he makes another covenant
with David. And God is progressively
revealing himself in covenants and
redemption history. And he does it in
the Messiah as well. With a new covenant
that we find inside the prophets. And
the Hebrew Bible tells us Moses himself
says that you have to listen to the
prophets that come after.
Yes, Moses does say listen to the
prophets. Okay. So, therefore, why you
not listening to the prophets? Why do
you say that we don't have to listen to
them?
Because it contradicts
what was revealed in the Torah.
Because
the prophets contradict what was
revealed in the Torah?
Because you
in your understanding this new covenant,
right? Is the covenant in what? The New
Testament, right?
The New Testament literally means new
covenant. Okay.
Which is in Jeremiah 31.
And so why
do Jews need
to follow the New Testament when we have
our old covenant
in which nothing is really changed or
improved upon?
Because there's constantly got
I don't know I think I feel like I went
through this already Avi, right?
[laughter]
Um the new you just literally yourself
admitted that in the time of Abraham you
can't go back to Noah. In the time of
Moses you can't go back to Abraham. In
the time of King David you can't go back
to Moses. So if we're in the new
covenant, the covenant of the Messiah,
we can't go back to David Moses. We
can't go back to Mount Sinai. We have to
operate we have that this is literally
what you agreed with me with in the
history of what was in existence, right?
So if you want to operate by the old
covenant, where is the Beta Migdash?
Doesn't exist.
Doesn't exist. So how are you relating
to the God of the earth without there
being a temple?
Because there's other ways to pray
without being at the temple.
You're missing the whole point, brother.
Missing the whole point of it.
Right?
You you that covenant is inoperable in
many ways because the temple is laid in
ruins. You always have to operate in the
governing covenant like we proved in
Daniel 9 24 to 27 which you said you
were going to refute, okay?
I didn't say I was going to refute
anything to be honest. I said I can
respond to some of the stuff you said.
Oh okay. Okay. So Daniel 9 24 to 27
gives us the time that the Messiah is
going to come according to Rashi, the
leading Talmudic exegesis and Torah
exegesis
in the Tanakh and inside the Talmud.
He's the number one exegesis. He tells
us that this time period is going to be
in the first century.
Where the Messiah the uh this time
period that they're talking about is the
timeline of the Messiah.
Judaism teaches 6,000 years of existence
of the of the world, 2,000 of chaos,
2,000 of Torah, 2,000 of Messiah. We are
in the year 5,000 and something. We are
in the time period of the Messiah even
according to Judaism. We're in the new
covenant.
Well, technically, the Messiah is not
mentioned anywhere
realistically in the Torah.
Right? You don't even need
Is he? Is is the Mashiach not mentioned
anywhere in the Torah?
Explicitly mentioned.
He's not explicitly mentioned? The idea
of a Mashiach is is not explicitly
mentioned in the Torah?
Where's the first time that the word
Mashiach appears in the Hebrew Bible?
I have no idea. Where is it?
It's in Leviticus.
That's why the Messiah has to be a
priest, my friend. And this is who
Yeshua is. This is why you need the New
Testament. And just to kind of bring
this thing back home, right? Kind of
take it back to the beginning. The
reason why you need a new covenant is
cuz the Hebrew Bible looks forward to a
new covenant. Moses desires that the
people's heart would be circumcised.
This is a mark of the new covenant, not
just on the outside, but on the inside.
And this is something only the new
covenant could do that the prophets look
forward to. And even these sages of
Israel tell us it started in the first
century.
So, you can feel what you want to feel,
but you're at odds with the sources of
Judaism.
And the Hebrew Bible itself.
But, I appreciate you coming on, man.
All right. Well, uh yeah, my phone's
about to die anyway. I got to go. All
right, man.
Um
Hey, I'm going to pray for you, man.
If you want to talk offline, let me
know, right?
All right. Thank you, uh Radar
Apologetics. I appreciate it. So, I
could say one more thing before you drop
me down.
Um like I said, I I don't think this is
a traditional
uh Jewish view, right?
This is not something that Tavad teaches
or or you'll learn, but I do think that
some of the stuff that that I said made
some sense. Um I think some of the stuff
you said made some sense, but I think
we're just at odds a little bit in terms
of our understanding, but that's fine.
Um
Yeah.
Look, I'll say this, you know,
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to cut you off.
Go ahead.
Oh, no, it's that was basically it.
Yeah. So, I'll just say this. I really
want you to examine your position that
everything has to come from the Torah,
and I want you to look what Moses says
about the prophet coming after,
right? Because in the Torah itself,
which you find as authoritative,
requires you to believe the prophet.
And also gives standards by judging
prophets.
So, your position's really a
self-refuting one, respectfully.
All right. Um Amen. I'll take that into
account. Hopefully, I
man. link up and discuss at a later
time. Cool, man. Love to talk to you
again, man. Blessings.
All right. I I'll see you. All right,
bye-bye.
Bye.